there are some sex crazed elephants
currently in africa in south africa
specifically because it's their mating
season there was a safari group of i
believe like college students going out
and a elephant went after them in a
sex-crazed uh trying to hump him yeah
ain't saving you they were trying to say
it was like pent up sexual energy so
big almost happened to me
is this
with an elephant or just like a dude
that's so scary that's so [ __ ] scary
man that is
music it's a musical friendly i know
that's like that's tasty probably
playing on the
jeep oh my god
see but this is what i want if i pay for
a safari it turned out you want a little
date but i want some [ __ ] yeah it'll
turn the jeep over and then oh yeah yeah
oh here we go oh there you go there you
go yeah it's not good
that lady runs not incredible she's not
yeah you're not in shape [ __ ] she runs
off seven flat foot well she's just easy
to catch damn oh man that truck's got it
but the music is so weird that's a
terrible thing yeah
you know what you cannot bring around
elephants you know you know what you
don't want to have in that cheap with
you a dog you know what they do
you got a rottweiler in there or
something they go oh your eyes are in
the front of your head you're a predator
oh cool very cool watch this
they'll reach in and grab that dog with
their trunk and throw that [ __ ] thing
really stomp it to death yeah they'll
kill your dog it's like a real problem
like elephants elephants are the biggest
[ __ ] in the animal kingdom when you
anybody who's been on safari knows that
they are we we were
in a jeep like that and they were it was
it was made with michael keith
thank you
michael keaton
i forgot that michael was there because
we did we went down together but we're
good friends yep and then you almost
died by an elephant well we had done
ourselves we had done a crossfit thing
and i did my friend in one minute 30
seconds
and then uh and then the elephants were
the adolescents were it was mating
season and they were all bunched up and
then they were trumpeting and uh uh
it wasn't like that but they were close
and they were
trumpeting at us they're aggressive they
were aggressive in the area
if i pay for that i want some [ __ ]
that's scary though yeah cause that jeep
ain't saving you
i mean i'll jump out they grab you bro
the elephant yeah grab you
you're picking that and they get mad at
you and they're like the guy thinks he's
you're 250 that's what i want on those
uh adventures like i want to see a lie
and destroy a dare i need some [ __ ] man
when elephants get a hold of you though
it's a bad situation have you ever seen
don't watch those videos but don't no
you should just step on it they'll mash
it up
they mash it up to butter they make they
make brendan jam out you that'd be cool
yeah